the United States was an experiment Shaz
is not it's not an experimental none of
these things are experiments Woodstock
Chaz flowerpower it's theft it is theft
and it doesn't work there's a lot that's
gone wrong with chat so much and the
media has totally miss portrayed it at
every turn to the point and the reason
we wanted to do this net what we were
expecting Jessa still be their club but
we thought it was important that his
Chas dies in a whimpering silence we
want you to remember this story because
the media wants you to forget and that's
a big mistake that I think Donald Trump
made by the way in relation to Chaz I
think you should have sent in the
military immediately after the first
death really because people say well
this let it self-destruct that that that
any strategy right now that is
predicated on Americans having a long
enough memory and that it won't be
tainted by this by the news cycle if
it's predicated on Americans remembering
Chaz in the media being accountable to
what happened with Chaz I think it's a
bad strategy well I think I think the
funniest thing is how it's ending right
now is that it's just collapsing them
but most people don't know right now
that's the problem I know you know cuz
we're political sort of work we're
political junky tossed Americans we'll
just say right what happened with chess
and so people would remember what
happened with Chaz after someone gets
shot in the park and Donald Trump rains
down on holy Hellfire on these studs and
creams I think so I talked to somebody
today who had not even heard of it and I
started telling the store and they were
like no you're serious like somebody
actually took over like a city yeah Park
the city was like like like a block I'm
like no like six block but I bet you
feel about the Seattle Summer of Love
they would remember it but yeah the
media that's how the media portrayed it
and so then when it goes away you know
they just they don't talk about it
here's a couple couple claims from Chaz
that are false and I want to know what
you guys think about Chaz and if you
think it's going to go away completely
and what you think the ripple effect is
let me know I'd love to see you in the
common in the made is at the zone is
autonomous right
that's a Chaz doesn't but then it
changed its shop because I think they
realized there could be legal
ramifications patient protests I mean it
was setting themselves up for failure in
the first place but I understand suppose
to a different level of failure and
what's what's interesting is that you
know even from the very beginning the
idea that it was overtaking
you know like let's say that maybe
started out as a George Floyd protest
then within like the first night it was
taken over by you know folks who were
like yeah let's join Canada you know I
mean it was just completely completely
different and overtaking from anything
related to the core issues that right
but so they said it was autonomous
here's the truth
Chaz only ever existed this is one of
the funnies there are communes that
exist go out and buy yourself some cheap
land it happens all the time
yeah that's how you can start a commune
I think Tim Poole is doing it now and
I've considered it could be kind of fun
I've considered it and then I'm like
reality so the problem is doing it on
someone else's [ __ ] yeah that's the
problem is now the communes as only ever
existed because was propped up by the
goodwill and works from a capitalist a
free enterprise economy of people who
were actual contributors they were
donating food more on good services and
other valuable commodities here and
there is a sign here that shows what
supplies they want this what you see
here was forgot my sign up there I like
after running for my life and I came
back to the next take someone to get it
and I saw this why was she winning for
her life and in May that seems like a
better story
we got cases upon cases of milk
yesterday the local businesses are
bringing paints of ice cream oh the mill
I'm guessing that didn't come from your
jazz farm what is it Ben and Jerry's ice
cream of course she just say she was
accepting the fruits of the corporate
tree you know small man you know I'm
glad that she made those glasses or self
petroleum products yes a recycled shell
of actual turtle terone that's like
rotella they have been backed up of
course by their corporate overlords
there at chas and a lot of irony is lost
on them because this support you'd think
that at least try and cover it up and so
our young men down there quarterblack
garrett and even brendan did actually
help them in checking their corporate
privilege and correcting it this morning
capitalist ideology any free advertiser
like on that
Gatorades and water bottles which is
marking off different logos
kappa with that I'm a panda the breeze
that [ __ ] done Febreze
Oh
sriracha can't catch a break document
they want them in the town then they
want to kick him out of the town because
it smells like garlic and then the logo
and the things people they're just so
easy to trick people are like no it's
not a slippery slope this cancel culture
and then you're like we're canceling
everything this is literally a slippery
slope because it's covered in bump into
the marker where you actually allow
someone to guilt you into Sharpie a Red
Bull which by the way won't last because
they don't understand the concept of
condensation yeah and the Red Bulls
pretty recognizable then the myth that
we've been told about jazz and you just
see this is and it's important because
people might look at this and go wool
was peaceful they just came up and told
you you suck okay but what about the
fact that in America right you can film
yourself or for example people say hold
on you're fine it's peaceful unless you
wear a maka hat but in America you can
wear Mogga hat and people have the right
to punch you in the face right there's
no there are no ramifications if there's
no reapportion
yeah so it's like a peaceful during the
day before the lights go out yeah if you
agree with them entirely otherwise they
invoke their own non-existent laws to
harass people let's just actually hear
it from Chris Cuomo and the mayor I want
to just get a clearer sense of this
though mayor why do you not just in your
city but in many instances when it comes
to what the remedy is for the unrest in
the country right now what do you think
this is about for him I think it shows a
complete lack of understanding and why
people are in the street there in the
street fighting a system of domination
and he doesn't understand that and his
response is always one that's bellicose
and militaristic but he doesn't honor
the military in that way either as
you've seen from the line of Jen
girls that have disputed him so I think
he says dominate because he is totally
does not understand what is happening in
America and he is desperately trying to
start the old fights in the old
divisions that put him in power in the
first place how long do you think
Seattle in those few blocks looks like
this I don't know we could have the
Summer of Love I don't like the fact
that she is downing on the military
response because hers is a military
response but the French village I don't
yeah so here's the follow-up tweet from
the mayor by the way more recently this
Capitol Hill autonomous zone is not a
lot less waste than it is a peaceful
expression of our know that's the
original tweet do we have the follow-up
tweet now where she's saying that she
needs to go in and get rid of the loss
and as you've heard this from the mayor
now let's bring that up and here's that
tweet three different people have been
shot at the chop it sounds like a steak
house the two were injured and one has
tragically died any incidents of gun
violence in our city well that's what
pissed her off those gun violence are
deeply concerning to me chief Carmon
best are residents businesses and the
greater community by the way that chief
hates you
yeah that's the most cops gun crunked by
the way what do you think happened to
the more silent crime like beatings
rapes
theft stabbings none of those are
recorded because the cops can't get in
there so the only crime we know about is
the one that you can hear because
there's a sonic booms just loud like two
Rams she's like I did not say it was a
lawless wasteland of yet when people
often say this by the way someone has X
has blood on their hands Donald Trump
has blood on his hands because he's
following the outline Barack Obama
Muslim travel moratorium right actually
this lady this mayor M she's known for
is this close to a politician having
actual blood on their hands as I can
imagine modern time people are dead
because of her exactly it's not just
it's not sometimes I disagree with
you've told people to go into a zone
that everyone else was saying it's not
safe it's not it's totally safe come on
down to jazz and then people like oh I
got shot she's uh
leave Jack now different tune I like
this guy oh I got shot normal response
this wasn't his first shooting okay
when's he hide I don't know but one
person is dead three people are shot
so people let's compare this when people
say it's summer of love and it's
peaceful what does matter is contact
yeah something to compare to so in the
United States there are four point four
six gun homicides per 100,000 people per
year this comes from the CDC four point
four six gun homicides per 100,000
people per year inch as they've already
had multiple shootings of fire putting
their rate at 500 Oh per 100,000 so
that's more yeah
so that's I can't do the math but
exponentially more Wow and if you just
take into account their actual violent
crime rate or firearm crime rate it's
higher than and I understand she has a
developing nation well give it time I
mean yes
when I say developing nation that's very
generous because it assumes hope they
are going quietly but they are they have
worse violent gun crime than other third
world countries they do are they are
they a fourth world country do we have
that I have no idea what's it have a new
category I made it up yeah we should
have a new cat it's like the bargain
what do you have next to the bargain bin
it's just it's just a trash it's like
free for less a hundred times higher gun
ownership I kind of like that part yeah
I think it's death from a firearm is a
hundred times huh but speaking of which
you know what else is actually I because
Raz Simone is actually he's a big fan of
fire Oh is he and we're gonna get to Raz
Simone the de-facto leader here who
provided us wonderful accommodations at
Simone's thank you so much res you're
invited to the house party at your house
by the way of course you would never we
would never be so just to not include
you that's true on the festive from the
goings-on at your property yeah you
would double the attendance yeah sign
the guestbook - yes he was picking up
sushi from his favorite spot right yes
and then he was loading it in his Tesla
right and he was gonna he was gonna stop
up pick up some mix tape USBs or yes
what long with a RPG which reminded me
even Brendon have the rub
door stop just have it ready
precautionary measure
so razz himself by the ways being a
fireman's he was caught illegally mind
you when he was a crime so these ones
that we've caught illegally handing guns
out to people and including people who
cannot in the state of Washington have
guns here he is on camera handing out an
ar-15 from his Tesla to a man who says
he's 18 are you over there he's 18 are
two years ago
he got that fast-food from the co-op
just one
[Music]
now look how he grabs this firearm here
he said would you like I thought it was
like a cap one oh my gosh keep that down
what rasz world by the way let's bring
up the overlay just in case you were
wondering is that a crime in Washington
yes it's a crime you have to be 21 I'm
not sure if that's depending on the
state if it's a felony or misdemeanor
depends on how many times you do it
certainly not legal probably most of the
devas a felony yeah there's not not a
great thing
would that be like in a court of law
video of Raz handing a firearm to a
minor would that count as evidence that
would be evidence that's not even a cool
like rap boast right
I gave guns to a kid yeah to a kid then
he shot himself and that's that's the
end of the story like I don't have any
wooden sad it's a sad tale to tell all
my b-sides but this is part of my plea
Raz is by the way living the American
capitalist dream to be clear people who
are following this guy he's worth
between 1 to 5 million dollars and I
know this is publicly of it and like for
some reason I am on black celebrity
Network how are you and it has me listed
at like 5 million dollars net worth and
it says that I have oceanfront property
in Dallas well yeah that's interesting
it's written by someone from like
Bangladesh like make much money from
YouTube video and have waterfront
property in Dallas and there's an old
Instagram picture from my grandmother in
law's lake house from like eight years
ago Wow so the point is that's I can not
entirely confirm this but I can confirm
that the City of Seattle awarded Raz
Symone 83,000 dollars write a grant to
help build his Studios which apparently
became somewhat successful yeah and
that's where he got all this luxury cars
my gosh a plethora of
and luxury rental properties he has
local businesses was it black umbrella
it gives one the aurora smoke shop okay
you know commodity Properties LLC and of
course he's a super host there at Airbnb
if it takes effort effort commonly
referred to as new chat supportive
capitalism yes did he just start hating
the man or because the man has been
pretty good to him it seems Raz yeah res
is the man well now he is he's always
been the man eighty-three thousand
dollar grant does that happen to build
the studio I'm gonna apply for I mean if
you if you ever just wanted it like if
you were just in you had a strong desire
to give money away that you were almost
guaranteed you'd never see again this
the people of Seattle have 83,000
dollars for that so razz studio I'd be
like I would take my money one just let
it fly away yeah it's like you build a
police precinct and then let the mob
take it oh right
exactly so at least the ring consists of
it was ever yours to begin with you
should let it go and it's covered in
penises so it did it just kinda doesn't
work with this saying it's gonna take a
lot of painting so rez has said Raz
simone again the host of new chess we
appreciate it ming so generous he's gone
on record saying that all he wants is
his piece being on the ground it's been
a bunch of peaceful humans who are upset
about all the injustice 'as they've been
seeing and specifically towards black
people right now just as under that pile
of lawn arena and you can bring them to
a duck no i'm not comparing oh god stop
with all the laminate but by the way do
you think he's so p think he had does he
say humans because people offended
somebody of mammals speech embody the
mammals who walk on two feet
have conscience the sentient beings a
sentient I mean like have the ability
like to like I am a human therefore is a
card I would like another grant more
money here you so he's talking about
peaceful humans well here he is actually
his latest video features graffiti it
says a good cop is a dead cop so seems
like it's not a literal when he said
peaceful he didn't mean literally
well he doesn't consider cops to be
humans I think is yeah that's oh yeah
that's that's I don't know listen to the
White Album one too many times away why
did we send Brendon Brennan's call he
thought it was the safer option sorry
speaking of which as a sensible man
here's a video of Raz physically
attacking someone while live-streaming
someone was live streaming from oh that
string did not end up with the Taco Bell
Drive no very peaceful though very very
peaceful so this is what upset Raz his
own audience I think is it wrapping of
Raz's woke red black lively has to be
he's gotta be woken I don't think that
we've ever even come close to broaching
the level of homophobia that Raz has put
out on public for all to see Lee and by
the way of course everything you're
about to see he'll claim he was hacked
no I was not hacked we can confirm so
one this is actually he's feuded with
other he's beefed with other rappers
know which is funny was doing research
something that was like a pro rest I was
like eat beef with other rappers like
Macklemore it's like it's like me right
now being like yo Mike Tyson's a [ __ ]
she's ducking me
[Laughter]
is feuding with Macklemore Macklemore
isn't the Mike Tyson of rap and that
anyone could call it's like when people
have like four subscribers or like well
I didn't cry no debates cuz with an
underscore in your sign Braz went on to
say Fitness yeah but he went on it he's
been he's been beating with rappers but
this is the actual rapper who was at his
level and he actually this is a razz
tweet I was always leery of like does he
mean what he's saying talking about
another rapper is he culturally
appropriate in gay people does he really
care about the communities that he's
speaking about and then he went on to
say can I say this are we gonna get
banned fine thank you okay I'll show it
to you where he's talking about this
other rapper who I guess may or may not
be gay just filled with human fluid
queer ass and then he wrote you get to
being a rapper as being the poster boy
for the fig community and bragging there
ain't no figs in my family wouldn't give
up the ass hole and wouldn't smash now
what's most offensive to me is that's
nonsensical
it really is I'm not sure I think um it
a hate crime laser in later in Razdan
people need to know who you hate you
can't just dirty bomb your hatred and
read some Strunk and white I'm gonna
come on Chinese are lazy I was gonna say
by the way I'd love that the first thing
that these guys did was build a wall
armed people at the wall and then
selected revs as their leader
these are thinking people right or
allowed that allowed him to take them
over just happen as I think I think
there was a black man and rasz so close
it's all so stupid were made for each
other yeah where I just think you sit up
he's like Chaz is mine now your choice
belongs to me we saw the movie you're
right I guess okay this is how it's
gonna be and then and then when someone
got shot and the mayor was like actually
now it's not summer love you have to
leave
no stay make up your mind if ever you
wanted to see the opposite of individual
thing yeah exactly and like you can't
find one person with a green thumb just
one person's like a that pot that you
put in you put in your plant it doesn't
have any it didn't have any dirt in it
and someone's like oh we need dirt I
thought it was cardboard and then
someone could just be like yeah you
should probably some dirt in that and
some water
and then they wouldn't all have to die
right yeah I mean is here it would be
easier you know I do I do have a
question about who's gonna what's
eventually the Summer of Love is over
which everyone knows in Seattle summer
really lasts like three days right um
and so maybe you know kind of if you
adjust the for that climate but who's
gonna pay to clean up the East precinct
who's gonna pay to clean up the the
field where quarterblack bitched out and
left
[Laughter]
we are cowardly and then you you know
you want to you you want him to die no I
really I really do have a problem that
this has been allowed to take root in
the United States of America what do you
have fifty something business is now
suing the city yeah yeah yeah I hope
they win this is a direct effect of and
this is one thing to like you can see
I've always said I will never run for
office and unless like maybe we'll be
like mayor maybe governor because we can
have a direct effect will be funny but I
would never do if I thought I could
improve a city because I can actually
there can be a net effect directly
attributable to your actions right and
in this case we have a woman who said
jazz is great summer of love go on down
the chess and we have businesses
destroyed and at least three people shot
God knows how many bodies are hidden
there and we had a complicit media and
just keep the reason this is so
important is because it's a microcosm of
exactly what will happen with the
violent protests just like now they're
trying to blame the coronavirus cases on
a rally they trigger is the rally yeah
exactly I don't think we could test that
right they're not putting out on any of
the violent protests where people are
not wearing masks and screaming at cops
thank God they have sneeze shields
I do find it remarkable they've just
completely forgotten about Jasmine's
past they just don't they won't cover it
and that's what's going to happen with
the protests as they go away and the
history books won't remember the
billions of dollars in property damage
the the many meant the dozens of lives
lost the hundreds of officers who were
seriously injured this is important
because Chas was the most extreme
example of the experiment that is
socialism in the United States there
really it wasn't but you see it never
ever ever works and of course what will
they say about Chaz well it just wasn't
the right person of course it wasn't the
right person who did it Roz wasn't the
right leader let's toss them into the
pile along with Stalin and Mao everyone
yeah everyone who has ever tried
socialism ever yeah let's just throw
them in there that's that's what's going
to happen and it's remarkable to me
because our kids will probably looking
back on just like people look back on
Woodstock farming to you Woodstock was
just a bunch of people who were drugged
out raping in the mud I'm sorry you
remember is something that it wasn't
we had video evidence that it was not
you think if you actually knew what the
flour the evil and the violence and the
unrest at the flower power era brought
back then that most people hated you
would want to see that Daisy in the
rifle going out the back of his hand
[Laughter]
what happened kids wanted to go to their
schools and they were being shouted down
and they were being attacked Woodstock
there are all kinds of reported rapes
that were never investigated in the
original Woodstock thing well I was only
99 no crime was worse crime was worse in
that era than in the late 1990s no I
guarantee and say oh I was mostly
peaceful how many people were shot yeah
just kind of five how many were shot in
the rest of the country at that point
like per capita hundred times less 1/100
but usable tomato we've dub
so I think you're right I think we will
look back in history on this and it will
be some kind of pared down version says
oh this was an experiment this was
something that people were trying to say
that freedom matters again right it was
this peaceful thing it was a summer
level that all those quotes but none of
the bad stuff it's none of the deaths
none of the beatings none of the people
who couldn't live there like you imagine
being a
white guy that lives in the middle of
Chas and you have to leave to go to work
are you kidding me you walk out the most
a lot of white people there well I know
there's a lot of white people there but
at night that guy was like yeah come
down here walk around sometimes and I
hate going through this place like there
was an element of fear just to walk
through there at night well it's not
because he's a white guy it's because a
member of chess yeah
chess is mostly white but to make you
kneel for black people that's my point
is it's jerilyn your whiteness is really
a huge part of your identity
it really is Steven I just want to make
sure he's white and wine well and tall
I have tall yeah it's so sad but I do
hate it when they say experiment no no
it's not experimenting if it's somebody
else's stuff you know what was an
experiment the United States of America
people who said that was a great
experiment well people say we need to
return to european-style socialism guess
what that's why we left and I know they
say well modern European socialism
versus monarchy no centralized
government a Church of England any kind
of state and force denomination taxation
without representation over taxation no
freedom of speech which doesn't exist in
Europe people not having the right to
bear arms to protect themselves in
radical government no fail-safes the
United States was an experiment Shaz is
not it's not an experimental none of
these things are experiments Woodstock
Chaz flower power it's theft it is theft
and it doesn't work and by the way if
you're conducting a scientific
experiment you start off with a
hypothesis and if it's proven verifiably
false you abandon it every time
socialism or some kind of a Chaz like
kommune has been tried it's been proven
verifiably false and I hate that
probably our grandkids will learn that
it was just something by the way if you
ever if you ever want to have a
counter-argument some people try and say
oh socialism has worked what they try
and point to is um is Catalina Catalonia
Catalan sorry Catalonia in before the
Russians came was it it was a 36 it
might either ended in 36 was 1930s who I
think was for about two years
cattle it was chats okay there was an an
arc it was a what socialist
anarcho-syndicalism
because no one should care about chess
in a few years but when people try to
point to some example that where you
look into it and they're all Chazz yeah
Chazz is just the newest in a long line
of many Chaz's right it's matter of
every time a Chazz like situation has
been tried it's always ended up like
chess yeah you like this video click one
of these other videos playing in a box
up there and hit subscribe or the
notification bell if you're already
subscribed so you can find out about our
new non controversial videos which don't
ruffle any feathers and of course are
not a violation of YouTube's algorithms
everyone's welcome here except oh I
don't know if we are but it's our
channel not sure how that works